[Music]
and how to ruin your career news
so easy right especially nowadays
you can really do it quick yeah you can
uh submitted by i love eggs
a model lied about being transgender
after making anti-trans
comments smart it's worth a shot at last
ditch
[Laughter]
that can be career oh my god very well
it could be
so they they talked [ __ ] and then they
went wait it's okay guys i'm trans
like that that's probably what happened
is that literally what happened like we
need this i need the story for this well
the girl right next to you has got it
all i know you
got you so this model her name is
carissa pinkston
and she what karissa pinkston
it's just is that an anti-trans girl no
it's just a funny name
yeah so this is what she looks like
she's a 20 year old model
and she modeled in the fenty thing
oh cool last year with the rihanna
rihanna which one is
this chick oh that's wonderful she's
pretty cool she got cool look
so her friend exposed her
because she had like her private
facebook page and she posted some
that's not a real friend that's wesley
that's no longer her friend
yeah that's a plotting ass friend which
means a friend of me which means she
never was your friend to begin with she
was just waiting for you to [ __ ] slip
so she could [ __ ] oust your ass
is that happening before no
[Laughter]
maybe i don't know so this is what she
posted on facebook
being transgender does not make you a
woman
it makes you simply transgender so
that's one
out of nowhere and then the other one
said the next day
being transgender does not oh sorry does
make you a woman in a transgender
context according to gender and not
sex this is how they want to be
perceived in a biological context
there are females and males this is the
world in 2019.
so the friend screenshotted these um
and oh i thought she was really talking
[ __ ] that what was bad about that
that's just a perspective from one angle
but i guess it sounds very anti-trans
that's what the person i'm just gonna
call her a friend
that's what the friend said that to her
just sent sounded very
anti-trans and so she ended up exposing
her
that's just [ __ ] up and then that led
to
her being dropped by her her brand her
label whatever it is management
so she ended up saying this on her
instagram that's funny
i wasn't ready to come out about it yet
but today i got fired and i've been
receiving hate mail and death threats
ever since so i'm being forced to tell
the truth i'm transgender
i transitioned at a very young age and
i've lived my life
as a female ever since it's been very
hard to keep this secret but what i said
about trans women
is a direct reflection of my inner
insecurities
and i have since come to realize that i
am a woman
we all are everyone's a woman
and then how did she get caught that's
[ __ ] up that she got fired though
that's
yeah it's always [ __ ] up that's that's
especially for what she said
and she's not ready if she's not ready
to come out you know
she's hiding behind that mask because
she's not ready
right i mean that was that's the last
dish
huh i mean i think in case of emergency
she broke the glass and she's like
[ __ ] she pulled the alarm well yeah
she's already drowning and she's like i
got nothing else to lose
her career was over yeah because of
those
screen shots now she just put the nails
on the coffin to make sure she stays
dead
exactly because god we are living in
such a weird time
oh yeah i'm still honestly trying to
figure out what it's all about it's also
depending on you got to think about you
got to think about your audience in your
industry right she's in fashion she's in
all that there's gonna be a lot of lgbtq
like
in that in that world right i guarantee
you if she made that state
statement at like a freaking butchery
industry
thing or whatever very specific like a
chicken like a chicken farming industry
thing like
there's not a lot of lgbtq group people
there i
i guarantee you and people are gonna be
like oh yeah okay so let's go on and
let's talk about eggs and [ __ ] but like
that was so the second
tweet especially was so generic in
general it was like reading out of a
science journal like is that
is that anti-trans is just science books
no i think it's the controversy
and like uh the it's it's controversial
right like it's it's like
it's like stating a point that isn't
favorable within
this group so whatever their talking
points are
in the lgbtq communities if it goes
against that then you're being
anti-whatever
right correct i think it's like what
joe's saying it's industry specific
so if you're in fashion and everyone is
that woke about lgbtq stuff and you say
something
that might have been okay in like 2017
but now it's in 2019 it's like boom it's
red flag but if we're at
tony's meat and cheeses no one's gonna
give a [ __ ] if you say those things
we're on a political because we haven't
caught up to it yet right like or like
like political debates or in school or
whatever like it's different
it's actually not anti-gay but the way
that they see it
is and what if you're you're on twitter
right
you're just on twitter and so you're
you're reaching every [ __ ] single
group
yeah yeah yeah therefore shut up
basically
because because you could reach these
people who feel this way like fashion in
whatever yeah yeah that's the part
that's
not really a a moral because that's
where she was it's not like she was at
the run
yeah no no but what the company's doing
is saving their ass because they know
their demographic right
so if the demographic is like of that
community and they don't want
any type of controversy they're like
well we'd rather not deal with anything
and they're gonna
that's just the business practical move
now morally i think that's [ __ ] up
yeah because they're not standing behind
the people that they're sponsoring or
or or they're employing or whatever well
companies never give a [ __ ]
yeah so she ended up saying that she was
trans right so then in that
in that comment section people are
saying it's terrible and disgusting that
you're lying to thousands of people that
clout [ __ ] is sad
and then they're saying like what lying
about being trans or not telling people
she was trans
and then this person said clarification
i'm not understanding how she got
srs at a very young age or when she
started hormone replacements
i do not believe she's transgender i've
seen baby pictures of carissa
i've seen her fully naked i've been
around this woman long enough to fully
know her
we have many trans friends uh this
conversation would have definitely been
brought up
she's and she's really ousted that she's
not trans and then she's that she's
persons
not trans at all so then it turns out
that she ends up saying
this which says i apologize for any
transphobic remark i've ever made
towards the trans community i panicked
and i thought if i came out as trans
that i could somehow make things better
okay she should be fired just for that
but it appears i've only made things
worse
duh truly sorry i'm only sorry i lied
i'm only 20 and i'm human no i make
mistakes but i refuse to let them define
me i hope
you all can forgive me and move on from
this because i'm so much more than this
incident i'm not a coward you're a
[ __ ] idiot take some time to reflect
on my actions and i hope
you all so stupid can try to understand
dude at least she admitted to it she
owned
it's very entertaining well her brain
isn't fully developed
there you go maybe worse that's true i
was dumb as [ __ ] at 20
exactly and this is funny but would you
have said
[ __ ] gay people wait just kidding i'm
gay
wait never mind i was only pretending to
be gay i'm only 20. i'm only 20. but a
lot of
a lot of gay people do that because
they're afraid of admitting that they're
gay in small towns like
they actually do do that because they
don't want anyone to know oh you know
they are coming up but then they say
just kidding but they really are
yeah that's a lot of layers yeah that is
a lot when i said [ __ ] gay
people i meant that i [ __ ] gay people
also like thinking back to i know this
isn't all like an order or whatever
but like i don't know who would rent a
kid to you
excuse me i don't know who would rent
you okay they don't know the context
around that but i'm just like i don't
think the other video i'm a friend
it's another video like babysitting
about that so you didn't know what was
going on in the store i was so confused
with this story it took me a while to
make it click because i would read type
of steve
yeah exactly you know what's going on
all right a disney rant video in case
you guys want to know i don't even know
if it's out by the way
our level sid i'm trying you guys are so
up there that's how crazy that uh what
do you call like mob mentality is now
where people
can just make a statement about
something and it's not even
wrong or bad yeah and people take their
own
position on it when it's just a neutral
statement like i'm sure i'll catch hell
just for saying our science books
anti-trans because i'm genuinely asking
a question like is that
what it's considered now yeah yeah is it
is it is stating like well you have
these chromosomes and you have these
chromosomes
and therefore is that is that
anti-translation
if i say like um okay if i say like
there's a way to talk about
you know gender and sex in a biological
way but also in a social construct
way right right and it's like can we
define the two does that mean that
i'm being anti-trans because i just want
to talk about the biological end of it
which is the sex part of it too right
because then like when people are saying
like gender reveal there's
there's other people in there saying it
should be a sex reveal because you can't
determine you can't determine their
gender until they're older
male or female so i'm like that's so
cool you also can't determine their
sexual preferences when they're three
years old or two years old or whatever
the [ __ ] people are doing like
like that's really [ __ ] crazy [ __ ]
let's just stop being so [ __ ]
sensitive please and just be all love
you know
like and and don't lie about being in a
community that you're not a part of
like mario do you guys hear about the
mario lopez thing no
he came out he never ages by the way he
basically can't he does not
uh he came out and said he was being
interviewed by somebody and he basically
said like his kid
um wanted to dress up as a girl or
something but he's not gonna
like that doesn't make my kid a girl i'm
not gonna let my kid make a decision
about their sexuality at three
and he had to apologize for that why and
i'm paraphrasing what he said i know
jesus
i don't have the quote in front of me
but yeah he he basically said that
he said essentially that and then he had
to
apologize for it because everyone's
trying to get them fired from me because
it sounds
transphobic uh to me it didn't but no
but to those people
that are angry but but then yeah it's
that's a
wide berth because i don't know man it's
like it's so dangerous
i get that you protect your identity
and that's a part of you and you know
you want to protect it right but then
when it just you kind of like start
skewing
things like the context or the intention
of what's being said
that's kind of taking it a little bit
too far so i have a trans cousin
not a bit and uh it's been interesting
because uh since i've known
this person because like they're on it's
like nikki's cousin
and then now they're my cousin and it's
been interesting because
when i first met this person they were
like a chick to me and like they had a
chick name and like it was just chick
and then now like um oh so you saw the
transition
i saw that right i've seen the before
and after yeah and
uh and now like he is doing like
hormone replacement stuff and like like
a deeper voice now and all this stuff
and now we call
him a different name so it's just it's
it's tough to
because when you meet somebody the
repetition's crazy like if i
i've only known bart as bart and i at
bart bart bart and when i see bart i'm
like what's up bart
and now i'm barbara right and so to
remember that you're barbara at all
times
it's a difficult thing because you're
structurally lo you structurally
visually look the same to me
does he get mad when you accidentally no
no no no no
but i feel bad right yeah yeah like i
feel terrible because you have a new
they identified a new way now yeah right
because you're supportive
yeah right i don't wanna be a dick if
somebody's like like whenever i
say to somebody i'm like uh on a thing
and people like well stephen you can
step over here i'm like oh i'm just
steve it's okay and i'm steve no babes
right like like when somebody tells you
please address me this way i don't have
a problem with that right you call
yourself
whatever the [ __ ] like that's fine too
so yeah i
and but but i don't but it's not
whatever the [ __ ] to me it's like a it's
like a big deal
this person's getting hormone
replacement all that stuff yeah but it's
it's um
it's impossible for me to imagine what
that's like where there's so few people
to talk to so few so little places to go
for
like like who else is going because
their communities are smaller
right so damn yeah so i'm i'm
sell them to like you know do
go bit heavy on it just because i'm
still i'm still learning about you have
any funny questions that you always
wanted to ask them
ask them funny questions i mean
not really not funny questions why are
you shaking your head well i grew up we
did you guys post those photos of me
looking like a boy everyone thought i
had
a transition when i was really yeah they
all thought that i was a boy
i don't know i told you guys i think you
have a better case for saying you have a
transition than this person ever did i
i
oh yeah oh yeah i was treated like a boy
and everyone said excuse me sir and it
was awful oh dang
yeah so i i know the feeling that's why
this is a really sensitive like topic
and i'm very like supportive of anyone
that wants to go through whatever
transition they want
because i know what it feels like to be
you're kind of being like discriminated
against you know because
for people that aren't supportive like
they're very judgmental
because in in my karate club there's
this kid and um
you know ambiguous looking i wasn't sure
and then they're like asking the teacher
question i'm like speak up
and then i was like hey she has a
question and he's like i'm a boy
and i'm all like well i [ __ ] that one
up [ __ ] man
you're trying to stick up for him too do
you know their name i thought it was a
girl the whole time
did he have like a like alex or yeah
what was his name i forgot he was new
but he had shoulder-length hair kind of
chubby so
this whole time i thought it was a
chubby girl you know what he should have
done what immediately hugged him and be
like i support you
that would have helped that would help
that would have he's like i'm a boy and
i was like
okay can i apologize i don't know what
to say at that point i was embarrassed
you don't apologize in karate you don't
apologize i was
i was shocked because this whole i see i
was like damn okay
i should have thought of that because
they don't wear a sports bra
so i'm like yeah
[Music]
[Music]
you